JOHN RITTER: Imagine
if you're a diabetic
and you can measure your blood
glucose level using a laser
rather than pricking
your finger,
instead, a person
can put their wrist
in front of a laser to
take the measurement.
Princeton researchers
are working
to solve real world problems
in health, technology,
and the environment.
University research can
have a meaningful impact
on people's lives.
CLAIRE GMACHL: We develop
new, tiny semiconductor lasers
that are engineered to emit
light in a very special way.
We can use them to
detect chemicals
for applications in the
environment, in health,
and security.
JOHN RITTER: Professor
Gmachl is exploring new ways
to use lasers to detect blood
sugar levels in diabetics.
A person could put a
device, like a wrist watch,
on their body that
would continually
measure their blood
glucose level.
CLAIRE GMACHL: We
do want to build
technologies that serve people.
So we look at society, we look
at the environment, and ask,
what are important
questions to answer?
Fields where there are
open questions, where
one can have impact,
and kind of do good.
On the other hand, I
wouldn't be a real scientist
if I wasn't also just motivated
by creating something new.
JOHN RITTER: Our
researchers are also
exploring ways in which humans
can more effectively interact
with computers.
For example, Professor
Verma and his team
are developing technologies
to make it easier for people
to interact with computers,
or other electronic devices,
using hand gestures instead
of typing on a keyboard.
NAVEEN VERMA: So the
technology that we're
interested in creating,
in some sense,
really focuses on
enabling interactions
between electronics,
or computers,
and the physical world.
A part of our research is
really interested in enabling
interfaces between
humans and computers
that are much more compelling.
Possible applications
for this technology
are extremely wide
and very diverse.
In operating theaters
for hospitals
where surgeons, once again,
in very constrained spaces,
need to be able to interact
with information that's
being provided to
them via display,
and things like gestures,
are very compelling ways
for them to interact with this
sort of information technology.
Because of course here we
also face the constraint
where infection can be
transferred if surfaces
are touched while a surgeon
is engaged in some surgery.
And in some sense,
these are applications
that we didn't
really think of when
we started working on this
technology, which are now
sort of coming to surface.
JOHN RITTER: All
of these projects
involve students
doing basic research.
For example, students in
Professor Kang's laboratory
are studying a gene
that is involved
with the spread or
metastasis of cancer.
YIBIN KANG: One of
the research efforts
that we have been doing
as of the past 10 years
is to find out
what kind of tumors
are aggressive based on
their molecular features.
And more importantly,
find driver genes
that make those
tumors aggressive
because that's the first
step towards treating them.
So in the end, we are now
able to tell the patients
whether they have a bad
tumor, but furthermore, we
can tell them that even
though they have a bad tumor,
we have a way to treat them
to stop them from spreading.
JOHN RITTER: The thing
that separates us
from other institutions
is our world class faculty
and researchers.
This is about research
that can benefit society.